take that first Adsense trick you're
like whoa what is this what is this yeah
yeah dude I remember when I got my first
asset it was like 300 bucks I was like
I'm rich a balla dude yeah I'm getting
that good water like [ __ ] Arrowhead we
going Eddie are we going you guys come
out to Little Tokyo look yeah we do
do you run into a lot of the crazy
homeless people here oh well I live
right by Skid Row so
oh [ __ ] though so you would enough all
of them I mean yeah said it is a baby
mama mama Virginia and my parents like
Korean daily gas station in the hood
okay
I grew up there oh [ __ ] cuz I'm not like
out there looking for trouble but just
Oh see that
that's the little Korean girl in you
that's what it is you wanna [ __ ] with me
I'm okay town oh you should've told me
k-town hooker okay boy I raised Virginia
your exact color don't [ __ ] with me oh
[ __ ] that's tight so you guys don't know
you guys think these like lifestyle
beauty bugs all sweet girls don't [ __ ]
with them that's tight I like that [ __ ]
so today we don't do your makeup like a
[ __ ] troll out [ __ ] I'll hang your
lips we will do some char past my brows
and you gonna do it with the race [ __ ]
you you're gangsters [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's
play no you said you live a Skid Row and
you know
that's our shooting up in detention oh
she was crazy this is my tent
well how was your like you my experience
with your parents especially like going
into like the whole YouTube scene and
fashion cuz obviously I don't really
think a lot of parents understand what
the fashion world is okay no they're
like oh what are you doing she cut a
clothes with the scissors I guess I
guess like for you for me YouTube was
always just it started definitely as
just a hobby but I did everything they
told me to like I went to a university I
graduated and meanwhile doing all that I
was still juggling my youtube channel
and then fitting in from the jump right
yeah pretty much I never really hit it
from them like well that's good I had to
my parents so I started in 10th grade in
high school
hey [ __ ]
ah
[Music]
yeah I started testing high school at my
parents house in my room with my you
know MacBook we all started off like
that but they had they didn't know until
like two three years later so when I
moved out to California and then I got
like that first you know deal and I was
like on started to make money you know
this kind of should be career then I
call my parents up and I was like okay
I'm going to tell you I've been doing
this since the 10th grade in high school
and you know I actually made a new
camera so can y'all help me out with
that
but they're never jobs cuz then they had
an opportunity to go on my channel and
see like the old videos from do you go
gonna do how old are you would you like
12 years old first of all just to let
you guys know I'm not that old I just
like [ __ ] next to them I look like your
father and I'm taking you to score I go
but I just came off a movie so this hair
is not how is Norma's book today and I'm
also 30 pounds lighter so I look like
[ __ ] next to you that's a big can I get
some makeup girls or something and you
just go ahead fashion me out real quick
said I was get a fade before my [ __ ]
bubbles like know any like my biggest
pumpkin uh so I have management and they
would tell me okay well you should go
out and meet youtubers oh my god I had
the same kind of thing right and so the
problem with me is that I always tell
him it's like he goes why I can't meet
them I was like letting you if they talk
to me they're not gonna like me well why
is that it's because they're gonna ask
me for my opinion and when I say my
opinion they're gonna hate me it's real
look it's too real for this I'm not
gonna say who this youtuber is but this
yeah we're asked me once he goes hey so
what do you think of my content no and
that's a very odd question to ask in the
first place yeah and I was like well in
terms of what was I think on me like I'm
doing comedy on his exact words or be
brutally honest okay okay yes I know I
think it sucks but the only reason why I
think that's because your communication
might are different it doesn't mean that
it's not good it's just that if you ask
me for my taste I think it sucks okay I
said but cliff
look clearly you're doing really well so
wiping it doesn't really matter
once again comedy is subjective yes
right so whether I find it funny or not
doesn't matter you have amazing views
you're doing really well cared you know
people don't recognize anything I'm a
very typical Asian face but is when I
speak they understand do you have a nice
tone oh great yeah you do you did
enunciate really well yeah why thank you
you what the funny thing is I actually
learned how to speak a lot more clearly
because because of YouTube I I was to be
extremely it was like I was rapping to
somebody I just say what for
I don't know rapping but I just thought
it's so good your first video is just oh
my god we have to circle the right here
[Music]
lots of privatize all the video this is
good for views cuz everybody's gonna go
back to your stuff cuz now you have like
all these like perverted boys on my
channel that constantly watching so my
birthday's next week David this next
week yeah between fit boy what's today
xx holy [ __ ] my rip is in five days I
know how old are you turning